[Music]
the academy awards have announced that
by 2024
all feature films will need to meet
several quote diversity requirements
in order to win best picture to satisfy
the academy filmmakers can hire
an african-american or native american
lead actor or
among many other things they can ensure
that at least 30 percent of the film
crew
has quote cognitive or physical
disabilities
mark stein is a legitimately serious
student of film he spent many
years writing about it and we thought
it'd be interesting to get his take on
what this means for the future of
hollywood and for art
in this country mark stein thanks so
much for coming on
this does seem like a kind of turning
point do you think that it is
yeah we used to mock the commies for
doing things like this
making politically uh compliant art when
the commies took over
in hungary in 1945 the hungarians loved
all their operetta
but the problem with operetta is it was
all full of merry widows gay hazards
countesses princes you couldn't have all
that in a communist state
so they ordered the uh the composers and
librettis to write socialist operettas
i had the misfortune to sit through one
called the state department store
it played about as well as it sounded
and we made jokes
about the communists for doing that uh
all the way through to the fall of the
berlin wall and now we're doing it 30
percent of
secondary roles under this new deal
uh are going to have to be filled by uh
made up of people from at least two
underrepresented racial groups so for
example you were talking about
the uh new african black panther
movement
and i would be quite interested in
making a film about them
but you couldn't under these rules
because at least thirty percent of the
secondary worlds would have to be black
and as we've just seen the new african
black panther movement
is entirely white uh so that film could
never get
made in today's hollywood uh this is the
death of art this
is art by quota uh and there is no
future in it
so it's it's not just i mean i think you
could make the case that
films are declining uh as
a a medium of influence in our society
but this tells you a lot about the
ability of creative people to create in
an environment like this can anybody
have a clear thought can anyone be
creative right now
no because creativity depends on truth
and actually creativity
is in decline over the last 100 years
we've actually lost the ability
to do certain things like uh opera
or representative oil painting but we
said it doesn't matter because now we've
got new things like pop songs
and sitcoms and motion pictures and we
can't do any of those too
hollywood has been propped up for the
entirety of this century
uh by mid 20th century superheroes
uh mostly created around 1964 by stanley
and jack kirby all the marvel ones
that have now turned hispanic gay
transgender muslim
but which people still go to see because
of uh what was done in 1964
and then uh middlebrow english
literature like uh jk rowling with harry
potter or ian fleming with james bond
we're dead creatively
we're dead and those guys who wrote if
you recall a few weeks ago that letter
to
uh harper's magazine by the big short
writers like jk rowling margaret atwood
the handwoods
tale chicky and all the rest of them uh
they are they were sort of oh we're a
bit concerned about this cancel culture
listen
listen uh margaret atwood jk rowling you
guys need to
you guys need to wake up i know some of
these people some of them were quite
helpful to me during my free speech
battles in
canada uh a decade ago and
and they don't realize now they're in
the the crosshairs
and they don't have five to ten years to
turn this thing around
if you don't want to be doing uh the
socialist department store operetta
you guys have got to speak up now
because this is the death of
art any movement that hates art and
nature
and they hate both those things is is a
very dark movement
and and i think you're right to frame
absolutely this in the terms it it
deserves it's not a small thing
mark stein thank you for that no it's
not
thanks a lot tucker